Bitte schön.
Guten Tag. Mein Name ist Zene Pilei-Filik.
Ich bin hier die Dienstabende Ersind und stelle Ihnen jetzt ein paar Fragen zu Ihrer kranken Geschichte.
Aber zuerst möchte ich wissen, wie Sie heißen.
Mein Name ist Lisa Müller.
Lisa Müller. Können Sie Ihre Vor- und Nachname buchen zu bieren, Frau Müller?
Mein Name ist L-I-S-A.
Ja.
Nachname ist M-I-L-L-E-R.
Okay, richtig.
Wie alt sind Sie, Frau Müller?
Ich bin 24 Jahre alt.
24, wann sind Sie geboren?
Ich bin am 12. Dezember 1925 geboren.
2.000.
Sorry.
12. Dezember 2000.
2.000, okay. Wie groß sind Sie?
Ich bin 1,72 m groß und wiege ungefähr 63 Kilogramm.
63.
Okay, Frau Müller, was kann ich für Sie tun? Was für Beschwerden haben Sie?
Ich komme heute zu Ihnen, weil ich heute sehr stark Bauchschmerzen habe.
Die heute wirklich sehr oder träglich sind.
Und die machen mir Sorgen.
Seit wann haben Sie Bauchschmerzen?
Ungefähr 3-4 Monate immer wieder.
Heute sind Sie besonders schlimm.
Seit wann sind diese Schmerzen schlimmer geworden?
Seit ungefähr einer Woche.
Können Sie mir sagen, wo genau die Schmerzen sind?
Die sind im Unterbauch.
Hauptsächlich im rechten Unterbauch.
Ich trahlen die Schmerzen irgendwohin aus.
Ein bisschen in den Rücken, aber der Unterbauch bleiben die.
Sind die Schmerzen dauerhaft da oder gehen Sie wieder weg?
Die kommen und gehen tatsächlich.
Aber seit 3 Tagen habe ich das Gefühl, dass Sie kontinuierlich da sind.
Können Sie Ihre Schmerzen beschreiben?
Sind eher dunkle, ziehende, brennende?
Was meinen Sie?
Ja, das sind ja so kampfartige, ziehende, manchmal strechende Schmerzen.
Wie können Sie Ihre Schmerzen bewerten auf einer Schmerzkala?
Wobei eines ist sehr leichter und eines sehr starker Schmerzen.
Gestern war es schon ungefähr bei 7 bis 8.
Haben Sie dagegen ein Schmerzmittel eingenommen?
Ich habe die Profin einlaufen, schon seit mehreren Tagen.
Hat Ihnen geholfen?
Ein wenig.
Haben Sie einen Ausflöse erinnert für diese Schmerzen?
Ich weiß nicht.
Manchmal habe ich das Gefühl, dass es nach dem Essen schlimmer wird, aber auch nicht immer.
Gibt es etwas, das Ihre Schmerzen verbessert?
Oder verschlimmert außer Nahrungs?
Nein.
Sind diese Schmerzen langsam oder plösslich aufgetreten?
Ich habe sie schon seit mehreren Monaten.
Ich würde sagen, langsam.
Haben Sie noch weitere Beschwerden?
Nein.
Ich habe Durchfall.
Seit wann haben Sie?
Auch schon über zwei Monate bestimmt.
Wie oft gehen Sie zur Toilette?
3-5 Mal am Tag.
Wie sieht Ihre Stuhl aus?
Durchfall.
Haben Sie in Ihrer Stuhl etwas Blut bemerkt?
Nein, habe ich nicht bemerkt.
Haben Sie viel, Stärflos oder Nachtschweiß?
Ich habe in den letzten Wochen, wenn man mit 37 Grad, 35, 37, 38 Grad schüttelt,
habe ich nicht.
Sind Ihnen über?
Nein, ich kann mich nicht nur erinnern.
Wie ist Ihr Appetit?
Weniger geworden.
Haben Sie in der letzten Zeit abgenommen?
Ich habe ungefähr 5-6 Kilogramm verloren.
In welchem Zeitraum haben Sie abgenommen?
Auch in den letzten 2-3 Monaten.
Schlafen Sie gut, Frau Müller?
Ich habe sehr müde.
Ich gehe mal früh ins Bett.
Haben Sie Probleme mit Wasserlassen?
Nein.
Besuchen Sie Ihre Frauen als regelmäßig?
Ich weiß seit einem Jahr nicht mehr.
Sind Ihre Regelblutungen regelmäßig?
Ja.
Könnte es sein, dass Sie zur Zeit schwanger sind?
Nein, das kann ich ausschließen.
Wann war Ihre letzte Monatbelutung?
Vor 2 Wochen.
Leider Sie an irgendwelche Vorerkrankungen?
Nein, gar nicht.
Ich bin in der Regel gesund, deswegen bin ich sehr unruhig.
Ich kann Ihre Sorge an gut verstehen.
Würden Sie schon mal operieren?
Noch nie.
Ich bin zum ersten Mal in der Krankenhaus.
Ich war noch nie eine Notaufnahme.
Hatten Sie einen Unfall?
Nein, alles ist gut gelaufen bei mir.
Nehmen Sie regelmäßig oder bei Bedarf Medikamente ein?
Ich nehme jetzt die Ibuprofen an wegen der Unterbauchschmerzen.
Aber sonst selten bei Kopfschmerzen?
Oder wenn ich eine Grippe habe?
Ich bin auch selbst in meinem Arzt.
Können Sie die Dosierung von Ibuprofen erinnern?
400, die man in der Apotheke aufbaut.
Sind Ihnen allergien oder Unverträglichkeiten bekannt?
Gar nicht.
Ich möchte etwas über Ihre Genussmittel gewonnen haben.
Rauchen Sie?
Ich hau mich nicht.
Aber Sie haben nie Maske geraucht, oder?
Ich habe nie Maske geraucht.
Ich habe einmal Objürt, aber ich habe keine Zigaretten.
Ich gratuliere Ihren Trinken und Alkohol.
Passt gar nicht.
Auch gar nicht.
Was trinken Sie, wenn Sie trinken?
Bei Feiern, Cocktails.
Bitte nehmen Sie diese Frage nicht persönlich.
Das ist eine Routinefrage.
Haben Sie Erfahrung mit Roggen?
Ich habe noch nie drungen.
Als nächstes möchte ich über Ihre Familienerkrankungen sprechen.
Leiden Ihre Eltern irgendwelche Erkrankungen?
Beide Eltern haben Bluthochdruck.
Sie nehmen auch Medikamente dafür ein.
Ansonsten glaube ich, dass Sie keine Medikamente nehmen.
Ich bin ein Schwester.
Ich habe zwei Brüder.
Ist er auch gesund?
Sie sind beide junger als ich.
Sie haben zwei Brüder.
Zwei Zingelen.
Sind Sie Zivilinke?
Genau.
Was machen Sie vom Beruf?
Ich arbeite beim Steuerberater.
Steuerberater?
Sind Sie verheiratet?
Nein, ich bin alleine.
Leben Sie alleine?
Ich lebe alleine in meiner Wohnung.
Haben Sie Kinder?
Nein, ich bin noch zu jung für Kinder.
Sind Sie gegen Kinderkrankheiten geimpft?
Das müsste vollständig sein.
Ich bin aber nicht sicher.
Aber ich denke schon.
Traben Sie regelmäßig Sport?
Weniger.
Ich bin in der Zeit, aber normalerweise gehe ich regelmäßig.
Waren Sie in den letzten sechs Monaten im Ausland?
Nein, ich war nicht im Ausland.
Ich habe meine Fragen schon gestellt.
Haben Sie Fragen an mich?
Ich möchte nichts hinzufügen.
Ich bin wirklich beunruhigt.
Ich möchte wissen, ob das Schlimmes sein kann.
Sie haben recht.
Ich kann Ihre Sorgen gut verstehen.
Ich möchte, dass ich Sie körperlich untersuchen,
ein paar Labor- und wildgeb embarungen zu circuitern.
Dann kann ich Ihnen etwas genaueres sagen.
Aber ich habe einen Verdacht darauf,
dass Sie Ihre Verdauungssystem Probleme haben.
Ja, okay.
Okay.
Ich muss alles überprüfen und mit meinem Oberarzt Ihren Fall besprechen,
dann kann ich Ihnen Bescheid geben, was Sie haben.
Aber Sie vermuten, es ist nicht Stimmnis, oder?
Ich kann jetzt nichts sagen, aber wir müssen beurteilen.
Machen Sie sich keine Sorge, Sie sind in den guten Händen.
Okay, dann mach ich jetzt hier.
Ja, ich bitte Sie jetzt um einen Platz im Wartes immer zu nehmen.
Dann ruf ich Sie wieder auf.
Okay, danke schön.
Haben Kollegen oder Kolleginnen noch andere Fragen?
Ein der Kollegen hat gefragt, haben Sie Atemnot?
Nein.
Haben Sie Schleim im Stuhl bemerkt?
Nein, ich habe Schleim im Stuhl, manchmal Westringen Stuhl.
Aber Schleim, so habe ich nicht bemerkt.
Ich habe auch keinen Blut im Stuhl bemerkt.
Sind Sie deswegen schon bei einem anderen als gewesen?
Ich war ganz am Anfang bei meinem Hausarzt.
Er hat gesagt, ich hätte eine Gastronomie verknüpft.
Er hat mir etwas gegen Durchfall verschrieben, aber das habe ich genommen.
Und dann ist es wieder aufgetreten, danach war ich nicht mehr beim Hausarzt.
Es war zwar ungefähr, ganz zweieinhalb Monaten gewesen.
Aber die Schmerzen waren in den letzten Wochen, also eine Woche so stark.
Ich kann das nicht mehr aushalten, das ist schon sehr stark.
Geleinenschmerzen?
Nein, Bauchschmerzen.
Haben Sie geleinerschmerzen? Einige Kollegen hat geschwistert?
So, nicht wirklich, nein.
Haben Sie bemerkt, dass Sie Haut oder Augen verperrend sind?
Hab ich nicht bemerkt.
Ich denke, alle wichtige Fragen geschwistert.
Könnten wir als erstes gesprungen fangen?
Ja, nur.
Eli?
Guten Tag, Herr Oberarzt.
Ich habe eine neue Patientin, die ich Ihnen anfordern möchte.
Haben Sie Zeit dafür?
Es handelt sich um Frau Lisa Müller.
Sie ist 24 Jahre, ein Meter 72 groß und 63 Kilogramm.
Sie stellte sich vor wegen, seit ungefähr 3 bis 4 Monaten langsam aufgetretenen
Unterbauchschmerzen rechts mit Ausstrahlung in den Rücken.
Und diese Schmerzen seien seit einer Woche schlimmer geworden.
Und die Schmerzen seien kramfartig stehende und ziehende Charakter.
Und die Schmerzintensität liegt bei 7 bis 8 von 10 auf einer Schmerzgala.
Dagegen nehme die Patienten über Profen ein, aber ohne deutliche Wirkung.
Des Weiteren klackte sie über die Erlösung seit 2 Monaten.
3 bis 4 Mal pro Tag und ohne Beutung.
Die Schmerzen seien nahrungsabhängig und begleitet von Müdigkeit.
In der vegetative Anamnese ergab eine Inappetenz und 5 bis 6 Kilogramm Gewissabnahme
in letzten 3 bis 4 Monaten.
Auch so wie Fieber bis 37,8.
Geneukologische Anamnese seien unhaffällig.
Die Patienten seien wegen dieser Beschwerden beim Hausarzt gewesen.
Und der Hausarzt einen Verdacht darauf auf Gastroenteritis.
Vor 2 Monaten.
Die Erkrankungen seien nicht bekannt.
Sie wurden noch nie operiert.
Sie nehmen bei Bedarf über Profen 400 mg gegen Kopfschmerzen oder ihre Bauchschmerzen ein.
Bei ihr seien keine Allergien oder Unverträglichkeiten bekannt.
Die Nuxen Anamnese seien auf unhaffällig.
In der Familienanamnese ergab eine arterielle Hypotonie bei der Mutter und meinem Vater.
Sie haben 2 gesunde Brüder.
Sie arbeitete in einem Steuerberaterbüro.
Sie lehnte und lehnte allein.
Sie seien vollständig geimpft.
Reiseanamnese seien unhaffällig.
Sie treibte regelmäßig Sport.
Die Anamnistischen.
Die Fragen nach Neusea und Hermes seien verneint.
Die Anamnistischen Angaben.
Die Anamnistischen Angaben deuten am Hessischen auf eine chronische entzündliche Darmerkrankungen hin.
Als differenzial Diagnostisch kommen Morbus Crohn, Hystrativ Qualitis, Reisarm-Sendromin, Wetteracht.
Zur weiteren Abklärung würde ich die folgende diagnostische Massnahmen durchführen.
Erst ist eine Körperleihuntersuchung.
Bei der Körperleihuntersuchung achte ich darauf, ob die Patienten Hausveränderungen haben.
Dann bei der Inspektion achte ich darauf.
Dann kann ich den aufabtasten.
Bei der Nagell-Veränderung.
Oder Glasnagell.
Oder in den Mund kann man auch auftasten.
Bei der Pargussion und Palpation achte ich darauf, ob die Patienten Abwehrspannung hat.
Bei der Ausgeltation höre ich die Darmgeräusche auf.
Bei der Laboruntergruhung würde ich ein kleines Blutbild und Entzündungsparameter CRPBSG Transaminasen antworten.
Als bildgebender Verfahren kann ich eine Abdominal-Ultraschall durchführen.
Dann eine Koloskopie durchführen.
Bei der Koloskopie, wenn es nötig ist.
Was würden Sie ausschließen?
Ich kann auch mit Ultraschall die akute Apandysitis ausschließen.
Oder eine Diwertikulitis kann man ausschließen.
Ansonsten ist die Ultraschall unauffällig.
Beidwürzigkeit, Nimmknoten.
Vielleicht kann man eine gelegene Geschichte schauen.
Vielleicht hat man eine Raumforderung.
Vielleicht hat es eine Raumforderung.
Deswegen ist Ultraschall eine gute Sache.
Dann kann ich eine Koloskopie durchführen.
Bei der Koloskopie kann man auch noch mal, ich kann nicht so gut hören.
Machen Sie sofort eine Koloskopie?
Oder machen Sie etwas anderes?
Oder ultraschallt ein Dreck Koloskopie am nächsten Tag?
Oder warten Sie erst mal die Blutwerte ab?
Ich warte so als auf die Blutwerte.
Dann führe ich eine Koloskopie durch.
Gleichzeitig kann ich eine Biopsy entnehmen.
Dann können Sie die Diagnose feststellen?
Ja.
Erwarte ich eine kontinuierliche.
Die Lokalisation ist in der gesamten Verdauungstrakte.
Die Kontinuierlich sind oder sind eher diskontinuierlich?
Die Kontinuierlich.
Landkartenförmig.
Sie hatten als Differenzialdiagnose Kolitis Ulzer Rosa genannt.
Was würden Sie bei der Kolitis Ulzer Rosa?
Wie können Sie die Kolitis Ulzer Rosa ausschließen?
Bei der Kolitis Ulzer Rosa gibt es kontinuierliche Lokalisation.
Sie begleitet häufig blötige Diare.
Wo freut sich das bei der Kolitis Ulzer Rosa meistens an?
Im Rechen oder im Rechen?
Die Morbus Kron lokalisiert in den Rechten und im Rechen.
Die Ulzerativ-Kolitis ist in der linken Unterbauch lokalisiert.
Was erwarten Sie im Blut?
Machen Sie Stuhlproben?
Ja.
Sollen Sie auch eine Stuhlprobe entnehmen?
Was kann man im Stuhl messen?
Im Stuhl kann man bei der Stuhl durchführen.
Sie haben ja auch eine Entzündung.
Wenn Sie eine Entzündung bedacht haben,
was möchten Sie dann in Stuhl messen?
Sie können auch eine infektiöse Geschichte machen.
Sie können eine infektiöse Erkrankung erhoben.
Sie können auch eine klinische Geistriertelkistik machen.
Sie können auch Entzündungsparameter wie Kalkprotektiv machen.
Sie können auch eine Entzündungsparameter wie Kalkprotektiv machen.
Wie würden Sie die Patientin therapieren?
Als der Massnahmen kann ich die Patientin eine Massnahme empfehlen.
Z.B. Leberstuhländerung, Nahrungsänderung.
Wenn die Patientin einen Akku hat,
können wir eine Steroidernverschreibung geben.
Bei der Langzeittherapie kann ich die Massnahmen immer depressiver antworten.
Man kann die Massnahmen immer depressiver antworten.
Sie können eine kurze Schub geben.
Sie wissen, wie viel?
Sie müssen die Patientin hier bleiben.
Sie müssen die Patientin stationär aufnehmen.
Sie haben gesagt, ich würde ein großes Blutbild machen.
Das ist ganz wichtig.
Das macht auch elektrophöre.
Sie können ein großes Blutbild machen.
Ich habe auch vergessen zu erwähnen, bei der Rundgenaufnahme.
Bei der Polytasulterase ist ein Fahrradschlauch.
Bei Morbus Kuran ist ein Pflasterstein.
Sie würden auch eine Rundgen mitmachen.
Was empfehlen Sie als Erstbehandlung?
Als Erstbehandlung würde ich Schmerztherapie geben.
Wenn wir die Diagnose wissen, würde ich eine Cortisontherapie einleiten.
Sie haben schon seit mehreren Monaten Zeit.
Ich würde erst die Diagnose feststellen und dann die Therapie beginnen.
Was meinen Sie?
Ich würde mit Novalgien beginnen.
Man muss die Patientin nicht nüchtern lassen,
das sei denn man möchte am nächsten Tag eine Koloskopie machen.
Ich würde das nicht empfehlen.
Das kann man im Verlauf machen.
Wir wissen noch nicht, wann wir die nächste Darmspielung machen.
Vielleicht kommt es am Freitag und wir können erst am Montag die Darmspielung machen.
Ich würde noch keine symptomatischen Schmerztherapie machen.
Erst wenn wir die Diagnose haben, würde ich die Cortico-Hittherapie einsetzen.
Wir können erst die Therapie sagen.
Schmerz, Medikamentation, Symptomatsch, Therapie, Schmerzen, Volumen geben.
Das würde ich machen.
Ich würde dann, wenn wir die Diagnose haben,
mit einer Lucho-Cortico-Hittherapie beginnen.
Sie haben gesagt, Koloskopie für die Diagnose ist gehalten.
Natürlich, eine Elekonskopie ist natürlich die Diagnose wegen der Polygysuzerosa.
Man kann das auch dort feststellen.
Man kann es auch nicht mitmachen.
Das kann man sicherlich mitmachen.
Wahrscheinlich hat sie die Beschwerden, das ist typisch für Morbis-Kon,
dass es im rechten Unterbau anfängt.
Dann würde ich auch dort, wo die Beschwerden sind, wo die Entzündung ist
und die Ulzeras sind, auch dort hinschauen und dort gegen Pazpiobsile nehmen.
Haben Kollegen noch andere Fragen?
Sie haben meistens im Terminalen Ilio, wo es anfängt.
Ich habe eigentlich eine Frage.
Muss man für ein Koloskopie ein paar Tagen warten,
bis die Entzündungsparameter sich abklingen?
Oder kann man das direkt machen?
Man sollte natürlich abwarten, bis die Entzündungswerte abklingen.
Man macht erst ein Ultraschall, man kann auch erst eine MRT machen,
wenn man das die Kapazitäten hat.
Aber wenn es akut ist, dann kann man vorsichtig eine Ilioskopie machen.
Wenn die Entzündung sehr stark sind, haben sie vollkommen recht.
Wenn sie kurz vor einer Selbst- ist, wegen der Perforationsgefahr,
muss man auch passen.
Ich habe noch eine Frage.
Muss man auch bei der Labor- und Versuchung Laktorferin bestätigen?
Oder ist das im Klinikalltag nicht so oft?
Ich weiß nicht, ob das weiter im Klinikeralltag gemacht wird.
Ich bin schon lange aus der Klinik raus.
Wir haben damals nur Kaltprotektive gemacht.
Aber vielleicht wird das mittlerweile gemacht.
Sobald ich weiß, ist Kaltprotektive inführen.